There are two types of
exercises on Udacity.
The first we'll call form exercises.
Form exercises involve some combination
of traditional form elements,
such as short answer boxes and
multiple choice questions.
Here's an example.
This is a simple multiple choice
exercise from knowledge base AI.
Here, I'll select one of
the radio buttons at the bottom.
Then I'll click submit.
I'll see some feedback on the right and
then I can try again.
After I've successfully
completed an exercise,
the dot at the top will change color.
Exercises can get pretty complicated.
For example,
here's one from knowledge based AI that
involves filling out several blanks.
Note that at first, your only options
are to look at the instructions again,
by clicking view instructions,
or to submit an answer.
To move forward, you must attempt
the exercise at least once.
However, after attempting it you
may choose to view the answer
if you're having trouble
with the exercise.
>> Note that most of our courses don't
assign credit for exercise completion.
They're really just here for
your benefit.
But some of the courses do.
Make sure to read your course's syllabus
carefully to find out if you'll be
graded on your participation
in these exercises.